what's going on the reject nation it's
greg al Bakir that is John over here
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
thank you for your service oh boy I'm
sure it's gonna be very heartwarming
very positive vibe yeah I mean thank you
presume okay mm-hmm any movie with a
positivity the title is usually a pretty
dark bill momentarily challenging again
alright let's watch this it's from the
the writer of American sniper didn't
interesting anyway plum Merrick in there
there you go
almost I believe movie love look for
bombs stop you don't see the bomb unless
they want me to would you got
I'll see nothing that you don't see
a soldier I had purpose and I loved it
he kicked some ass over there yeah yeah
we wanted it to be perfect my favorite
girls is perfectly getting later in life
oh yeah wait maybe the clone arrests one
evening sorry for you Megan
I want to chocolate chip smiley face pee
for you she doesn't like talking okay
it's an accommodation Mary the details I
can take anything but climate on that
these young going to see you fold you
did a job at the years thank you alright
alright
we have to be too perfect the best
Pacific incident that troubles you know
this one [ __ ] civil lives everyone I
gave up on Grayson
[Music]
thank you for connecting missing a lot a
year
we're brothers doing a future after all
the blame on me
sick image right there yeah dog tag
hanging has a tons of powerful video
that movie is gonna make me cry probably
a lot there was not even a specific
moment and that truth as I made me teary
I just like all the emotions oh yeah it
looks like a really good movie I like
American sniper a lot actually I like a
good story about you know more better
than dealing with PTSD it seems like
it's gonna do it in a really good way
miles is mop seller Shia LaBeouf role
that means every child hostage oh damn
man it definitely looks like those
better than when I've heard I don't
think that we got through the grill yeah
yeah I mean these kinds of movies always
fascinate me and I didn't actually see
American sniper I know that movie was
kind of controversial but this yeah I
mean this looks like a good story for
the now especially you know the the the
toll any anything that involves like you
know the the struggle to adapt back into
regular life and all that stuff you know
is always kind of fascinating to me and
there looks like it's gonna dig deep you
know give me people that have actually
been to war you see that matters my mind
cannot comprehend what that must be like
to come back to here if I ever meet a
guy like these can't have give them any
[ __ ] or any advice I had to like
deal with life because I I would never
know where to begin because I don't know
what it's like all to be in a person's
shoes like that oh yeah I mean you
jumped forward into a completely
different platform of light yeah like it
a completely different set of
experiences that you know after a
certain point it's hard to go backward
you know it's hard to react LeMay when
you know I would imagine
the horrors yeah and the real because
that's the thing is like I just believe
that nothing could ever prepare you for
that experience no matter how many
simulators or movies you watch or
whatever that's the main concern with
for me with movies like these is just
the authenticity and it at least feels
like the stuff we saw this trailer feels
authentic yeah and I feel like miles
teller is doing a route it's going to do
a pretty good job because he he seems
very subtle and I like you know me I
like characters who have to really
contain what's going on inside of them
where there's a lot that wants to come
out but they they're constantly trying
to keep their cool it's like the little
touches of life that I really appreciate
in the show like what he's making the
chocolate pancakes yeah as I'm like
chocolate and his response to that would
I guess I missed that like you could
tell there's more going on in that
delivery oh yeah he didn't like this I'm
gonna go suffer I know you'd see that
there's you miss out a life coming and
getting crap over this day and I'm like
one hit a man is deal with the aftermath
and stuff and he does have at least in
these in these sequences that we see in
this trailer like he does have that sort
of like it's just a normal day until you
know yeah he doesn't seem to be playing
it like a guy who's just focused on this
you know it's either very human very
real naturalistic performance one thing
that I appreciate about what I'm seeing
from the trailer - is it seems to have a
lot of heart a lot of times when you see
these types of stories told and even
from just trailers or the movie itself
weirdly sometimes I feel like the thing
that films missing is a heart like
through the sense of camaraderie amongst
the brothers the really big sense of
love between the husband and wife here
as well as the trauma and the darkness
is all layered inside of it because one
thing that stretchy we capitalized on is
his relationship with a Haley Bennett
it's also really showing the camaraderie
he has with his other soldiers he was in
the troop with us I appreciate I said of
this a trailer of a guy who's breaking
down freaking out the whole time as well
as an authentic layer to that as well
because there's a lot of War veterans
who do suffer that way you see this guy
who's really trying to he's hailed as
the hero and he wants he's trying to
just keep his composure together the
whole
Clym and I mean it seems like the these
movies are all the better with the more
facets of life they explore and that's
what I got kind of the most out of this
trailer in all the different facets of
the situation you know because when he's
talking about like you know you I don't
think it was my rig you know one of
those guys somebody said you know you
have a purpose and you you know what
you're doing and you know you belong you
know you see elements of that but then
you see the horrors there's that scene
where he like backs up and he's covered
in blood like yeah and then you see you
know that the nice moments at home and
they hinted the tough moments at home
and there's that moment where he looks
like he's the VA or some kind of you
know like official building like dealing
with some kind of logistical nightmare
it seems like it's going to kind of
cover everything that the returning
soldiers struggling to acclimate back
into regular living we have to deal with
and that's that you know alone makes me
interested in this you know interested
in the experience it seems like it's
gonna take you on a human experience and
I guess my one concern with this is what
miles teller was is great in like the
one drama I think you you you all can
reference were mild colors ratings
whiplash and he's done other works as
well really good in it yeah he's done
other words as well where he's really
goodness and a lot of comedies
especially but I know mob so there's a
kind of actor when I see a trailer like
this where I can imagine people being
like I think I can believe miles teller
in this role I just he's that after who
I know people will respond that way -
yeah everyone I just know there will be
a lot of people who will from seeing the
trailer and knowing other great dramatic
performances he's done I doubt he would
do a bad job in this film oh yeah I mean
I generally think miles teller is a
pretty terrific actor and he seems like
he's very good at embodying nuance and
and you know mannerisms and things like
that and the only other concern I have
with a movie like this you know what the
only other thing I'd be worried about is
getting Hallmark II you know it's always
hard to tell you know with with the
trailer just how human and how nuanced
something is going to be I mean with
these movies that deal with this kind of
subject matter you know it's it can be
enormous you know so yeah this is
oftentimes the messages are kind of
thrown in your face
yeah when really the
effective way to do it is just do a
strong character portrayed yeah no don't
tell me make APA yeah like me that's
that's how this is the most effective is
if you just put me through that
emotional experience a little bit you
know even move a human after all don't
put the brain Oh me I thought I was a
cool reversal this is the beginning of
the trail at baseline kicks annually
right seems like it's cool right now
that like a cool vibe like look how good
he is at his job and then you know the
singing kicks in the lyrics and it gets
you know a bit more heart heavy and then
by the end you like oh I get it
some people go real problems kid is it
loose yeah hell yeah
have you heard something no you heard of
some human not out of outside of time
only human after road will put the brain
all babies maybe once like on a
commercial it what's up right come on OK
ROCK oh I just haven't listened to radio
we should get back into summertime now
my job and loop it and easy in the
summertime when the weather's clear were
juggling our gone subscriber the real
rejects click that notification valve
John is get John - John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram without Joestar
tops hum and you can check out our
patreon patreon comm flesh the real
rejects where we are exclusive perks and
videos so go check it out
subscriber screen junkies and I'm Jan
Moreau